using evidence from more than 33 million
marriages
that's a lot of marriages
and 67 million births in England and
Wales from 1837 to 2022 we show there
was never within this era any period of
significant hypergamous marriage by
women I'm going to read that again
33 million marriages were studied
again this is not a survey this is a
study and 67 million bursts in England
I'm not really sure what the births have
to do with the marriages but they're
looking at all this data from 1837 to
2022 that's a vast amount of data we
show there was never
within this era any period of
significant hypergamous marriage by
women now before you go and burn your
rational mail book
Rolo isn't wrong
um so when I take a look at this data
and I click through over here so here
I'll just throw up on the screen we'll
kind of go through it together
and we'll have some time for some
call-ins today I'm gonna do a little bit
of a little bit of a shorter show
tonight guys so
um if you have questions come in early
because I probably won't be able to do
the full 90 on this one
um where is the window there it is
all right well I'll throw it up here
so this is an excerpt from the study
um the study is uh I think it's a Dutch
study if I'm not mistaken
and um
hypergamy Revisited marriage in England
1837 uh it's widely believed that women
value social status and marital Partners
more than men leading to female marital
hypergamy and if you're new to the
Channel all that really means is that
women tend to marry across and up on the
socioeconomic scale it's not always been
up it's across and up there's a
preference for at least at a bare
minimum as good as she's at but they
prefer better it's not often they'll
marry down it happens but not often
a recent paper in Norway for example and
by the way this is a February 2023 study
a recent paper
on Norway for example reports
significant female hypergamy even today
as measured by parental status of men
and women in Partnerships so apparently
in Norway it happens but not not in
England during the years they studied it
using evidence for more than 33 million
marriages which already quoted here we
show there's never been within this area
any period of significant hypergamous
marriage by women the average status of
women's fathers was always close to that
of their husbands now
this is where it starts to get a little
weird and you have to re like you know
the devil's in the details right like
you have to pay attention to the wording
because right off the bat they're
basically saying women aren't
hypergamous they've
there's no evidence of it in 33 million
marriages within England and Wales
but
the average status of women's fathers
was always close to that of her
husband's fathers this this study is
based on the parents of the married
couples
not the married couple not the groom and
the bride but the parents
the average status of women's fathers
was always close to that of their
husbands fathers so they're not even
looking at the Family itself they're
actually looking at the fathers
her father his father consistent with
this there was no differential tendency
in England of men and women to marry by
social status the evidence is of strong
symmetry in marital behaviors between
men and women throughout there's also
ancillary evidence that physical
attraction cannot have been very
significant factor in marriages in any
period
1837-21-21 based on the correlation
observed in underlying social abilities
does the study reveal that women aren't
hypergamous as they summarize it no
again I think it's misleading using
evidence for more than 33 million
marriages and 67 million births in
England and Wales from 1837-2022 we
showed that there was never within area
of any period of significant hypergamous
marriage by women now
I thought this was interesting because
I'm like
you know at face value before you start
looking at it and then you like read the
fine print where it's not the bride in
the groom it's the bride's father and
the groom's father compared
it's entirely plausible that the parents
are at the same level
which is probably pretty common like in
1837 because
you know you pretty much all did the
same thing you either worked in a
factories you're you know the revolution
started to happen the Industrial
Revolution the communication Revolution
all this sort of stuff happened over the
past 18 37 to 2022 sort of thing but you
probably did just about the same thing
you probably lived in the town doing
just about the same thing you probably
met in a church or a school doing just
about the same thing right
today's a lot different
now I kind of went through the exercise
of diving into people that I know
personally I thought the easiest way to
do it was just go through my Facebook
friends list and I went through every
single person I know that is either
married or has been married and I know
both the couples personally like I know
who they are I know what they do for a
living I've met them I've broken bread
with them or I've had drinks them
something right like I know them
personally
I'm not one of those guys that's like I
have 5 000 Facebook friends because I
I'm popped I don't give a right so
I went through the mall and what I found
was based on my friends list based on
that experience about 78 of women
married up not across up for the most
part some were close to a cross but
mostly up there were a couple of
scenarios there was two scenarios in
fact where uh the guy in the gal the
husband and the wife
are still married have been married for
over 20 years and I know for a fact that
they both started with nothing and in
one of the cases she actually bailed
them out and lent him a ton of money
maxed out her credit uh to to give him
money to get the business off the ground
which paid off for her you know at the
end of the day
um again a lot of the people that I know
um are in the GTA or in North America
and they've either been married or
they've been divorced but I know them
personally and you know like I said more
than more than three quarters the women
married up so I think this summary
saying that uh what does it say here
there was never within this area any
period of significant hypergamous
marriage by women
foreign look at the data and it's
collected on the fathers
the fathers of the groom and the bride
anyway
so I don't think it's honest and to be
honest with you at the end of the day
I still see hypergamy I think it exists
I think it's real I really hope you guys
enjoyed that clip if you want to watch
the full length podcast you can find
that over here that clips from if you're
new to the channel make sure you hit
subscribe over here and pin down below
in the top comment you'll find a bunch
of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out